produce from all over the world passes
through this warehouse
and since the invasion of ukraine much
of it is getting more expensive jj foods
is a wholesaler so price rises here will
reach all of us eventually and the boss
has never seen anything like it
i'm 25 years in the company i've never
seen as many price increase letters for
my suppliers in my life early part of
the year we are out of the
energy price increase so that had the
impact
obviously the war in europe is not
helping either
but the trend has been upwards since
january
and
the coming out of the pandemic has also
created some extra demand in the market
inflation was rising before the war
began and the bank of england thinks
it's only going to get worse
the bank raised interest rates for a
third successive meeting by a quarter of
a percent taking the base rate to 0.75
the same as before the pandemic though
still low by historic standards
last time the bank meant they were
focused on keeping inflation caused by
the post covered recovery in check but
war has changed everything six weeks ago
when the bank of england's decision
makers last met they didn't even mention
ukraine now they've taken an
unprecedented step into politics by
condemning the invasion which will
fundamentally affect the economic
outlook for all of us causing inflation
to reach at least eight percent possibly
higher last even longer and intensify
the squeeze on household incomes
an energy crisis compounded by conflict
will be the biggest driver of inflation
and war has sent commodity prices
soaring
supply of 30 percent of the world's
wheat from russia and ukraine is in
question and global growth is slowing we
had global growth at close to 4.5
percent um projected for 2022 in
december um so it's a shock and it may
evolve and there's a risk that it
worsens if as the situation evolves
but so far the shock to gdp is about one
percentage point
the chancellor has an opportunity to act
in his spring statement next week under
pressure to delay planned tax rises and
help consumers who are ready to lead the
recovery given the chance paul kelso sky
news